hello everybody
um and good morning good afternoon or
good evening
depending where you are in the world
today and
uh wherever you are around the globe i
hope everyone is keeping safe and well
under current circumstances i'd like to
now take some time to talk with you
about the importance of working with
your
cmo during product development
how the cmo can help you can assist you
and really facilitate that development
process to make sure your test gets to
market when you want it to get there
and at a at a cost and budget
that is in line with your expectations
so before i dive into that detail
i would just like to uh take a couple of
moments just to give you an introduction
really
as to who and where we are
and what we do essentially so
i guess everyone everybody would would
agree that 2020 has been
a relatively uh challenging year so far
and they have been i guess significant
changes
for everyone around the world there have
been a number of changes within
uh habit and health i mean over since
the beginning of 2020
uh where we are now it's almost a
complete a completely different
company in terms of what we have
facility wise
so just to give you a quick sort of
rundown
regarding that so beginning of this year
we had
the one manufacturing site where we also
had
r d tech transfer sales and marketing
finance
essentially our headquarters and that
was at the
york biotech campus athuma is outside
the historic city
of york in the uk and it's a
biosecure site and we had been there for
a number of years now one of the
challenges
that 2020 through witness was a
requirement to significantly ramp up
our production capacity you know to meet
the demand
for tests relating to the global
pandemic
but also to keep in line with our
customers
business growth so to that end there's
been significant investment at abundance
so we now have a second
manufacturing site which is based in
doncaster um
in in the uk and we still have
a uh satellite r d facility
based in the west midlands that
expansion hasn't just been if you like
for uh the manufacturing footprint and
the actual
square meterage they have also been
significant uh investment in terms
of people and the required equipment so
if you are uh
if you have been involved within the the
lateral flow world previously or
something that you were not researching
you you would have very heard uh brand
names such as uh
biodog ginolis kinematic
etcetera so we've invested heavily in
uh new uh biodot realtory region
dispensing equipment auto laminators and
we
have we'll have multiple genola systems
uh live before the end of the year which
uh very uh
which are very much the um
cutting edge really in that sort of
final assembly piece when assembling
the latter flow asset device
because of the nature of the business
we're involved with as you would imagine
our sites meet all quality standards and
certifications
required and we've
basically grown since 2008 by um
acquiring complementary diagnostic
businesses not not only to strengthen
our position
within this particular market but also
really to
enhance the offering uh that is open to
to our customers not be it for contract
development and then manufacturing
or pure contract contract manufacturing
in terms of what we do
as i previously mentioned it's there is
a choice
um flexibility is key
basically so we have a global client
base
uk europe north america far east
and we essentially are a contract
manufacturing organization
specializing in rapid tests specifically
lateral flow assays we also have
a contract development component to that
so
we can be involved if you like directly
in the development from start to finish
then transfer
to manufacturing or it can be pure
contract manufacturing after the test
has been
developed elsewhere however
regardless of at what point we're
involved and what we are responsible for
we always have the same core focus so
we're relatively unique within the
market in that
you know we have developed and
manufacture
some of our own ambulant health branded
tests
and the quality management system
processes procedures that we would apply
to our own developments
and old manufacturing is something that
we apply
to our customers also so that core
core focus is very much um
high quality robust manufacturable tests
and
that's something that we will touch upon
a little later but you know it's
something which really cannot be
stressed
enough the best test in the world
could be developed every bell and
whistle you could possibly hope for
but actually when you come to
manufacture that test
if that consideration hasn't been there
from
very early on you may find that it's it
just
simply can't cannot be manufactured for
a reasonable cost that is going to
enable you to hit your market pricing
you know and
and obviously can have a major negative
impact
on the performance of our test within
the market and your business plans
so we very much focus on robust
high quality manufacturable tests
everyone can think uh challenges and
issues that
that uh present themselves during
development are unique to that
development but
we've been involved in this field for um
long enough time and across a multiple
different
uh industry sectors you know to know
that
there isn't much that can be uh that can
kind of challenge us that we haven't
seen previously and you know
we would have something in in our
metaphorical uh toolbox
that could be used so in terms of the
different industries we have developed
and we manufacture tests for
human health animal and veterinary
agricultural environmental food and food
safety infectious disease
and environmental diagnostics so
each of those different type of tests
can have different challenges in
in terms of how the sample matrix
maybe may be collected may be processed
how the sample matrix will impact
perhaps the biological reagents etcetera
so
any good symbol with its salt you know
will
will have a strong pedigree in in terms
of
manufacturing a wide variety of tests
you know and
they may have a history of test
development
also so there is potentially a great
source
of information and assistance as you
move through your own particular
development over recent years uh we have
developed the uh
appdx technology also so and
that's that was simply um a response
to the requirement from our customer
base to perhaps
move away from uh benchtop-based lateral
flow
readers more towards a smartphone
based system so we
that's something that we've been
involved with for um a number of years
and really how that uh
appdx looks and is customized uh
for your particular test or a particular
test is
very much up to um your
requirements and what you want the end
user to see and how you want them
to use on that smartphone reading so you
can build in things such as
test choreography timers barcode readers
etc
or have something that simply
takes the result displays it to the user
and stores it and
stores it in within the phone memory on
the other end of the scale
uh having cloud connectivity and then
that data being accessible
by uh
very uh security um via a
secure portal by for example
a clinician to assess
the uh progression of a particular
disease state of things or things of
that nature
so i was just giving a quick quick
introduction
as to as to why i'm basically here today
um
i personally have been involved in the
lateral flow
um field for probably come up to
eight years now um i believe and
although uh i do have a background in
science i was a humble microbiologist
for many years before
um venturing into biotech and r d
um and rapid test development it's been
a good 20 years since i last
worked within a laboratory so you will
be
um you will be pleased to know our r d
director has told me on numerous times
that
i will never set foot into one of her
laboratories so so you can
rest assured um your the transfer to
manufacturing if needed
is done with a safe pair of hands and
you don't get me
involved at the same time so
but why why outsource lateral flow
assay production there's
a number of different areas to consider
really so
there's a financial benefit so for
example if
lateral flow assay production is not
your core business
um by outsourcing that manufacturing
you're then removing the requirement for
quite significant quite heavy
capital um expenditure that budget may
be then used for other purposes perhaps
revenue generated uh project
uh projects and of course
it isn't enough just to have the
equipment uh we know from experience
you can have the best equipment in the
world but you've really got to invest in
your people
also and although much of lateral flow
assay production you know
can be as automated as as possible
you still need operate as a production
staff of
a high skill level and many with a
scientific background
at you to be able to
manufacture those tests to meet the
specification
agreed prior to the whole thing
transferring in
so by outsourcing you're taking away
that people cost also
obviously if lasher flow asset
production isn't your core business
then by outsourcing the manufacturing
you can then focus on
on on your core business you know
aligning those activities with
high priority projects for example and
really enabling your workforce your
colleagues
to do what they do best so if that is r
d
then crack on with the r d don't worry
about the manufacturing outsource it to
a company that
is trade and trade um is tried and
tested
and trusted within the business
there's very much that element of um
future
future proofing the business so so for
example
um within any manufacturing
agreement there will be agreed quality
criteria
quality specifications qc testing uh
agreed lead time delivery times etc
so you know when you pl when the order
is placed
for the required number of tests
they're going to be delivered by the
agreed to by the agreed
delivery date i know and there's no
issue or challenge for you
in the future by losing key personnel
involved in
um the manufacture of those tests
if you're doing them in-house and how
that could impact the business so
by outsourcing business you outsource
the risk
at essentia which is something that um
a number of people have taken advantage
of uh over the years because
it really is it can really be a very
positive impact
on uh your future business activity
of course flexing you the operation
in line with demand so
tests transfer in there will be a
routine manufacturing
batch size but but essentially you only
need to purchase
what you want in line in line with your
sales forecast
and if any
cmo um
[Music]
is worth doing business with then they
they will already have um supply
agreements with
major materials manufacturers so
you can really then implement a fixed
cost
management process you know there should
not be
any unexpected spikes in terms of
material
in the materials cost if you have
if your cmo has those agreements
in place as the relationships there and
can then manage that
manage that process for you
again really this is all about i guess
outsourcing
um risk again and really
why you reinv why reinvent the wheel so
by using a good cmo they will already
have the equipment in place i mean here
you've got a couple of images of
the genoa system they will have
established processes
they will they will be certified you
know with various regulatory bodies to
um
i've already got the people there so
you've got the equipment you've got your
people
and you've got the processes all already
in place no need
for you to spend money spend time um
to put those in into your facility
so it takes away any time associated
with
ordering equipment for the best will in
the world
sometimes a bottleneck can be
equipment lead time so take away that
and of course any spikes
in demand you know can be quite easily
handled
by your cmo as long as you've done the
due diligence
side of things you've chosen a cmo which
has the capability
to really respond to
pressures the market may exert on you
perhaps in terms of increase in batch
size
increasing the number of batches needed
or a relatively short space
time you know so the shabo has to have
that has to have that some
capability that footprint necessary to
if need be
in in increased production to meet to
meet your requirements
how can a cmo assist you otherwise well
use the user schema to become more
competitive you know to do that if
you want stable long-term pricing so
as i said previously your cmo should
have a robust
um strong supply chain in in place
and can make use of that existing
supply chain and uh
logistical processes in place to make
sure that you've got that long-term
manufacturing cost you're not going to
be
experienced unexpected um spikes in in
terms of
in terms of cost and it allows you to
plan properly
and also allows your cmo to plan and
really
unreally um uh enhances you know
which the the partnership which you know
it really it really should be
something i'll talk about a little bit
later you know is that
you cmo shouldn't just
be a manufacturer insight you know cmo
should really be your
eyes and ears within the marketplace so
there may be regulatory support required
which certainly
has been for and a number of companies
recently with the changes to uh uh
european regulation
now they make logistical support
so rather than the cmo
expecting you to supply all the raw
materials
um biologicals the componentry
and they manufacture and then ship and
they ship back to you
to ship on to the customer there may be
a requirement just simply because of
available space within your facility
that actually
the cmo will will handle um
the supply chain the logistics for
all of the components of your test
um you know there may even even be areas
in terms of commercial activity that
that your cmo could
assist you with perhaps access in
different markets through
existing distribution um and channel
sales networks the cmo
already has etc and i guess the
the last area i would touch upon really
is
again it's about that outsourcing the
risk it's it's the support and
reassurance so you will obviously have
within a cmo a dedicated project team
that may handle the transfer of your
tests into routine manufacturing
but you would have a dedicated account
manager
there would be points of contact within
quality qcqa
um operations and those regular
routine calls business reviews
etc you can make sure that your cmo
activity is aligned fully with your
business goals
which has been which really can't be
emphasized uh stressed enough during
the current situation with uh the global
pandemic you know
that they read there's had to have been
a much greater cooperation and contact
between uh customers and cmo
to make sure that those tests are
delivered
where they're needed um to the right
people
so i think we sort of covered why
there may be a requirement to outsource
lateral flow assay production and some
of the benefits
outsourcing the production can um
give but i guess we should
talk about well when should the cmo be
be involved now i
from from my perspective um and from my
personal opinion
um i would say as early as possible
um there has to be that focus
in development from a very very early
stage
how that test is going to be
manufactured how that
test that our the r d scale those are
bench scale
production how is that going to be
scaled up
materials processes equipment all need
to be considered as a very very
early stage and so otherwise you're
simply not going to achieve
high throughput production and
the capability to produce
routinely high quality robust tests
to meet your desired timeline to get
into the market
uh to get a foot in the door essentially
versus versus your competition
now how can the cmo
assist you well at those early stages
there may not be any direct experimental
work that the cmo
would assist you with but there is that
advisory capacity you know again
you don't want to reinvent the wheel so
working with a cmo from the start of a
development
can significantly reduce risk
um and i really can't stress enough that
what can work in r d may not translate
onto the large automated lateral flow
manufacturing equipment you know so
for example the materials you initially
choose
for the r d work may be perfectly fine
in terms of
uh uh flow rate for the sample
um to move through the test
you may see a nice positive line and
when you get to that point within a
development if you if you develop a
sandwich i'll say but the worst case
scenario is
that material perhaps under the
cellulose membrane the material that
you've chosen
it simply lacks the tensile strength
that it can't be used
on a really automated system you know
and again
having to change something at a late
stage
in development or as you're transferring
to manufacturing
is going to be costly in terms of money
and and time so you know i do i do
everyone listening to to really consider
using a cmo
to save you time and money and don't be
invent the wheel
if the cmo will have advice we'll
know the best options in terms of you
know that sample matrix
that type of test that you want to
develop and manufacture
and as an advisory role you know can
really make a positive impact
so this diagram
really um
illustrates some of the typical stages
if you're like during a
uh development pathway for a lateral
flow assay
you know so where where in our pathway
you know should you involve
a cmo well i mean ultimately it's your
it's your choice
um talking from personal experience
uh from an abbott and health perspective
as a cmo we can be involved right to the
beginning
um so if a customer for example decides
to
outsource not just the manufacturing but
if it's a you know if flash or flow is
non-core
to the r d team you know they may decide
to outsource
some of that risk of the development um
and outsource the r
d to us also so and obviously
that's gonna if that's possible you know
it's gonna depend whether your
cmo of choice um is purely manufacturing
or also has a development capability
also
so for example as i said in case in some
cases we can be evolved from the very
early stage proof of concept
and we operate a system here which is i
think it's common to
uh many companies
um within the rapid testing
sector essentially it's a very modular
approach with
feasibility to optimization to scale up
to technical transfer so
where your test may fit
into our pathway you know will be
dictated by
how much work how much r d has obviously
been done
prior to it coming in to us as a contra
manufacturing
organization so typically if a test has
been
developed it may be uh
developed up to the end of optimization
and it's then time to scale up
and then transfer for routine routine
manufacturing
so that's a very common approach uh
that scale up is basically necessary so
for example within r
d um you may have been manufacturing
tests uh on a very sort of bench scale
uh
bench top process and
perhaps there's been no um uh
no testing of of that initial disorder
of that design
on you know common biodog realtor real
system
um you know in terms of in terms of the
autolaminator
et cetera so that scalar processing is
is very important to make sure that
what's being done at an r d scale uh can
be
scaled up effectively onto the
manufacturing
equipment and it's from there then
moving moving to the uh
technical transfer and then ultimately
routine manufacturing
but again this is something that your uh
cmo
should be aware of and you and really
it's
it's your choice but your cmo should be
prepared
um you know to be involved at those
earlier stages even if it is from
um an advisory
uh perspective just to make sure
as we said previously you know the
materials that the odds that you're
looking at
um the processes that you're considering
to manufacture they are all suitable for
high throughput routine manufacturing
so if we talk about a little bit uh
further and look at it in a bit more
depth really
so where should you involve the schema
well
one thing for me is materials
so you could look at it as
what does successful manufacturing
involve you know from a lateral flow i
say well
um you conjugate your labels on your
antibodies effectively
those labels could be uh gold
nanoparticles and they could be
the goal could be spherical it could be
nanorods it could be looking at
cellulose
beads could be looking at fluorescent
particles
platinum carbon you know there's latex
there's a whole host of particles you
know obviously you want the best
particle
for your particular test so you
conjugate the labels
to the antibodies effectively you know
you select and and apply the the right
reagents it's impossible surfactants
things in those nature and components so
you know like your cells membrane you
want your sample part your conjugate
pad your upper wick assemble all that
into
a housing make sure they all work
together
um you know to deliver tests according
to your uh
quality specifications i mean sounds
easy doesn't it you know but
um i think we all know that
the in each choice in each element
within those multiple working parts of
the lateral flow assay
if if you don't get that particular
component right
there will be a knock on there will be a
knock on effect if if that
if if that the issue with that component
carries on through development you may
come to the point we want to transfer to
manufacturing and your cmo
may point out immediately look we've
used
we've we've used that particular
material in the past
we know we know it causes problems x y
and z
now you then have a choice
the test can be manufactured as is with
that element you know and
and really um you know accepting that
element of risk of that particular
component
or there's that uh choice there
to spend time money
to swap that opponent out so so again
having the cmo
in involved you know at a relatively
early stage
you can make use of the cmos experience
and and really there's no need
as i've said previously um and forgive
me if i repeat this
number numerous times no need to
reinvent the wheel
if you're cmo that you've chosen
you know has the experience and the
expertise when it comes
not only to manufacturing tests but also
what's developing tests and
they will be able to assist you with all
with all of these
um areas that really should be
considered you know so for example
there's a as you can imagine there's a
huge variety of different of uh
sample matrices depending on what the
test
is going to analyze and who the end user
is going to be
so if a test is being developed and it's
whole milk
there's that high fat content to
consider
if it's whole blood you know you want to
strip strip out the red blood cells
so it could potentially mask
the red test light if it was in gold
there's a whole host of um things that
you can say i mean saliva
uh the the number of times i i
i've been you know i've been in a
meeting and we're talking about the
development and plus manufacturing of a
saliva
matrix based test you know and
people will always sort of agree with
that sort of right smile that you know
yes
you think saliva should be an easy
sample matrix because it's 98
water uh it's the other two percent that
causes
all of all of the challenges really to
uh uh
overcome so what are the best materials
to allow high throughput automated
production because
if you if you plan on um supplying
in into your market you know 100 200
500 000 tests a month you don't was made
by hand you know
um you wanted to be as automated as
possible to drive down
drive on the manufacturing cost you know
and to take away
as much potential human error as
possible
now in terms of those materials does
just does your cmo of choice have long
term supply agreements now
this is this has become
an important important factor really
during this year you know because
there has been such a demand from a wide
variety
of companies to develop a covey 19
test you know so luckily uh
we've been in this game long enough that
that we have very good relationships you
know with
uh major sailors membrane suppliers uh
suppliers of sample pads
you know backing card etc that we are
we already have those agreements in in
in place
and we can work with with our vendors
and to um
to assist us if our demand in
increases now um you know i shouldn't
wouldn't want to be
in a position this year of suddenly
going out to the market looking for a
supply period next to sellers
membrane when it was a huge demand
for that particular material so there
may have been stock issues
the i mean the other thing to bear in
mind um in terms
of uh osmo having a robust supply chain
you know not only that no risk to the
continuity of
of supply number but for example any
uh any required changes in
uh material perhaps i think is being
discontinued you know so you need a cmo
to be
have that relationship with the supplier
to be able to manage those those
component changes you know and
we need to again to be your uh eyes and
ears within the market not to know
if there's something that's approaching
on the horizon and it could impact you
know
the material you need to produce your
test then
having that relationship having that
knowledge beforehand you know can go a
long way
to uh minimize any any negative impact
you know and again i know something that
i missed previously but just
having that and having that experience
having that expertise to know well
are those components that have been
selected
are they suitable for automated
manufacturing
so again uh you know where should we
where should you involve
uh your chosen schema well
a good cmo will not only have experience
and
an expertise but they also have those
processes
in in place so using your cmo at a
relatively
early stage you know prior to a test
transferring in
and will ensure that the assets being
developed can be transferred
in efficiently and within
a really optimized time frame
so to get that test into routine
manufacturing get that test out
to your to your customers so again you
don't want to be reinventing the wheel
you know
um you want to use those sort of tried
and tested processes and procedures that
as i mentioned previously where's it
i've been done the same procedures and
processes we use
for our average and health branded
products are those that
are applied to our uh contract
manufacturing tests and you know it's
going to mean that those
critical process parameters and control
points associated
with the process with the equipment and
already going to be defined you know and
um the those plot processes
is going to provide a reproducible and
robust manufacturing you know
process the last thing you want is to
have
errors quality problems batch after
match of the batchman that just
should not be the situation whatsoever
so by involving your cmo
at the newly point within the product
development you know
keep in those touch part touch points as
the development
proceeds we are
going to use um and you know we are
going to make use of your
uh cmos expertise experience and their
existing
automation on their existing equipment
again reducing the
uh reducing the requirement for you to
spend time and money putting these
things in place
i'm sure you sure you yeah you're aware
um
lateral flow and immunoassays or lots of
fluorescency tests
can be manufactured by hand you know but
through team manufacturing you you
really want that to be automated as
much as as much as possible by working
with a cmo at an
early point you you're going to know
you know you you're going to have that
um input from a cmo regarding well
in terms of a test design what is
suitable for automation
what is not so things that we need to be
considered
um as you can imagine the equipment to
be employed to manufacture
you know the r d batches perhaps in
in-house um how does that equipment
compare
into the matter of fact the
manufacturing equipment your cmo
will use so as i mentioned um
how does your equipment compare to for
example uh the buyer dot relative real
reagent dispensers
uh auto lamination equipment
things of that nature
and ultimately how translatable
is your r d production
to routine production with within within
the cmo
okay so again have having those
conversations
um having input from your cmo at the
particular points
through through the development you're
really gonna
all that prep work is going to be done
so
what you want from the cmo then is an
efficient
fast optimized transfer to manufacturing
okay nobody likes any surprises
essentially
i've mentioned technical transfer a
number of times i mean
in many cases um this is actually where
we would anticipate seeing tests
that you know that may have been
developed elsewhere may or may already
be
uh uh commercially available and there's
a requirement to transfer them in
to a symbol so it's basically a process
where you verify that manufacturing that
routine manufacturing
process um is suitable you know and it
really basically spit the two areas
uh you know i'm sure that you're aware
of this in terms of batch manufacturing
so accurate reproducible and
robust assay that allows repeatable
batches to be to be produced
and to meet the quality criteria
so typically um we would we would kind
of three
uh manufacturing three transfer transfer
batches
there's also that documentation element
to it obviously to make
the batch records are are completely
which which
can go into uh the necessary
technical dossiers perhaps used for uh
regulatory
purposes and i know i think a key
element is that you know obviously your
cmo has to take the lead
with regard to this process um
it's in the cmo's interest to move that
test into routine
into into routine manufacturing you know
and
i i can't think of any cmo that would
want to
um purposely extend that technical
transfer
process you know but a good cmo will
will also
also resist the temptation to cut
corners you know because
you really have to demonstrate
repeatable production
of batches in terms of quality in terms
of not only the product but also
also the repeatability and robustness of
the process in place you know and
cutting any corners
is just the recipe for disaster further
on down the line so i i would urge
everyone
to really as a slight suggest to take
the lead from the cmo
with regard to what's required for
technical transfer
so i think we've um you probably heard
me say this
uh a number of times you know but if you
can
uh you know talk to your the or even if
you haven't thought about
manufacturing you know i say you know
yet i mean speak to companies
involved in this field um
even if it's primarily for
uh advisory
input um it's it's going to be worth it
it's going to be worth your while and
um by working with that cmo you know and
having that cmo in place ready to accept
the test
post development for for manufacturing
it is really really going to assist in
that development process you know
and really make sure the quality
management system that the cmo
is working to is suitable
however and the one thing
i would i mean i would always i i i
would always suggest people to research
and before choosing a cmo you know is
what do they offer except manufacturing
i mean the um
the cmo should be your at least your
eyes and ears
within within the market you know so in
terms of you know
helping you through that's a regulatory
and commercial landscape
so what ready what regulatory support
is there now you may find um
you may find a company can develop a
lateral fluorescein
it can manufacture a lateral flow assay
up to
a certain patch size company may develop
the tests
may manufacture and you know up to the
batch size
you know 500 000 test plus um
you may find other companies that purely
all they do is contract manufacturing
now what your the question you also have
to ask is you know well
what can you how can you support me in
terms of that commercial and regulatory
landscape now something i'm i think
we're
very fortunate within abundant is
because we've developed and manufactured
our own tests and
we have had to make that investment in
terms of
a very strong qa and ra
department so we can support
our customers in terms of current and
future regulation
will that be some fd fda's of uh
510k that obviously should be um extra
marks if anyone
noticed that before me um ce marking
and you know the imminent implementation
of uh
ivdi so so as you know by i think
i think by the 26th of may 2022
um all ivds sold in the year you don't
need to adhere to
the new uh ivd
r i think it's 2017 forward stroke
746 so you know which replaces the
original
ivd now
it's thought that this will impact 80
percent
of ivds actually sold within the years
and so
so your cmo should
already you know have been very much
uh not only aware of of what's coming
down the road you know but
working with their customers to
assist them in what needs to be done
what changes need to be done
um to get those tests marked market
ready
now you'll see the cmo may also
have the capability you know to and to
be at the
legal manufacture status on on your
behalf you know so
but there's no there's those other
areas that the cmo can assist also you
know so um
packaging solutions you know it's it
at some points actually getting the test
device
assembled into a file pouch where the
desk and label is that
may be almost the easiest part of of
that process you know
you've then well what about all the
peripheral
components etc so perhaps you use your
cmo
within the development process to advise
and assist
on well what's going to be the
optimal sample collection method sample
treatment
what componentry would be required what
are those sort of commercial
um aspects that need to be considered so
potential distribution uh channels you
know
even supporting you within commercial
negotiation
so there's a whole variety of um
aspects where the cmos your chosen cmo
should be able to assist you with you
know and
be much more than just a manufacturer so
i would just like to take uh
a couple of minutes just to really give
you um a bit of a case study here which
really shows all areas however cmo
um can assist
assist you so this um
relates to the abc19
rapid test so
this is something that we undertook as
part of the uh
uk europa test consortium um
taking on the lead manufacturer
um status so
we were involved from a very early stage
in that developing the test
you know which was really done um an
exceptional uh timeline in in terms of
um that development development process
you know and you
you could argue the point well if it can
be done for this test it could be done
from
for other tests but um this was really
a sort of valid effort from from
colleagues with within r d and
and tech transfer you know sort of
working around the clock
split shifts um and really applying
as much resource as was needed to get
this important test
developed you know so it's essentially
um
an antibody test looking at the uh igg
for use through um
[Music]
the population uh
whole blood fingerprint test now
this is this is an area where
we've been involved as i said in the
development
we have uh we
we with other consortium members will be
manufacturing
the test but we've also been pivotal
in terms of the regulatory
aspects so really taking on all of those
uh necessary um
workflow requirements to facilitate this
test being developed
manufactured and out into the market
where you know it's
it's it it's a very important test
that is needed to uh respond to
current events so i guess in
um i guess
all i can do is thank you for your
attention um
you know i i hope you will i hope you
found this uh
interesting and informative i look
forward to
any questions and
thank you for your attention
jonathan thank you for that outstanding
presentation
we will now move into the live q a
portion of our presentation so now as a
reminder to our audience
please submit your questions via the q a
box
jonathan our first question if you had
to give someone
one piece of advice about developing a
test for manufacturing
what would it be um
i think the best piece of advice
i could possibly get would be don't
don't cut corners um
the will always be
the um
the option from you know from from
some development companies some
manufacturing companies or even
internal pressure you know to really
speed things along
uh you know because ultimately to get
the test out into the marketplace to
start
generating uh revenue but often that can
be you know
a recipe for disaster essentially and so
um any any development pathway you know
there will be elements of that
of that development which can run in
parallel if the
if if sufficient technical resource is
is available
but wherever there's the temptation you
know to perhaps actually well
we just live with the the potential risk
of
not doing x y and z in the development
and then
we do them at the end if need be then
that can just
you know it is just just uh kicking the
can down the road
and there could be a whole host of
unwelcome surprises
when you are ready to transfer it into
manufacturing
that have to be remedied at that point
sure thank you what size batches should
be produced when a test is transferred
into manufacturing
um the one thing to bear in mind
um well i mean just to give you the sort
of habit of the health
approach so we would manufacture uh
three validation of three transfer
batches now
we tend to take the approach of so
low medium which is probably not not the
right words
to use really but the one thing that
should all that should always be the
goal is that
third and final validation batch should
be at
the anticipated um routine production
batch size
so that will that will be based on the
customers initial sales forecast
the reason being you you want to
demonstrate that that test can be
manufactured
um in a repeatable way but
it can be manufactured at the scale it
is going to be done
on a routine basis so
you don't want to transfer a test
manufacturer and say for
10 000 you know a batch size of 10 000
tests
and then within a couple of months
there's the realization that the test
has taken off in
in in the market and actually a hundred
thousand tests are needed per batch and
there's a whole host of things to look
at then in terms of conjugate stability
um qc procedures etcetera you know
and they can't be an element of work
then to scale up to the required
routine batch size so
low medium high but that sort of high if
you like is the routine batch size
thank you for that answer now we have
some great questions coming in
so i want to make sure we have time to
answer them let's go with this next one
um great job john given the current
pandemic there seems to be a lack of cmo
capacity globally
does abington health have capacity to
take on new projects
yeah i mean it's it can be a challenge
it can certainly
it can certainly depend on
current production schedules except i
mean we're very conscious that we have
um we have customers that have been with
us have been done
before the pandemic and will be with us
after the pandemic so
we certainly have made sure that
those customers have been prioritized to
to maintain
that continuity of supply but i mean
it's one of the reasons why
um uh our ceo chris says took the
um some decision we need to invest
make sure we invest in the
infrastructure into the
manufacturing capacity equipment
footprint
so we i think by the end of this year we
should be up to a million tests
a week to party and there'll be uh i
think there's another expansion
um planned for next year to take that
further
so there is capacity available i mean
you know it's very it
it it is in high demand um but we are
approaching it you know with a
sort of cool head and um you know
very methodical mahana really you know
so to make sure that
the orders are in um customers are fully
aware
it's very transparent as to what the
lead time is
is going to be and we've been looking at
um
modified sort of weapons etc so not just
bringing in
extra equipment but we but we've also uh
greatly increased
the uh the workforce within those areas
to make sure the capacity is there
that's great to hear good our next
question
let's see um
are you able to help new startup with
guidance on how to
obtain grants funding in order to help
them get through the development process
for example with gays foundation
submissions
um yes yes i mean we can you know we um
we have a long history of with
a wide variety of um companies are from
from
spin outs from universities through to
well multinationals so
yeah i mean if foreign
i can i can respond to them directly
with my contact details
and yeah you know we could certainly
have a chat and uh
if i can advise them or a colleague
great and we do have all of everyone's
email addresses for those who are
submitting questions so
any questions we are unable to answer
today and any of the questions that come
in during the on-demand period
uh you will be able to answer those via
email so
we have time for just maybe two more so
let's squeeze a couple in here
um does abington do microfluidic
cartridges
too and would you have a recommended cmo
for microfluidics
um we don't currently um
again i went offline and speak with some
colleagues
um and there may be some companies
suggest you know we're very sort of
collaborative
within within the industry and there's
lots of uh lots of possible connections
there
that we that we can call upon so yeah
i'll
reply to that person then if if we can't
help
or if we can finish see anywhere
great and um let's go with this question
because it seems like a very popular
topic
in 2020 right now obviously um currently
are you still being approached to
develop tests that are
non-coded related absolutely yes and
um i i must confess when we are you know
it's
it's an absolute breath of fresh air you
know it it seems to have been
everything's been covered related since
it seems all you doesn't it so um
yes yeah i mean there are still tests um
being developed out there which uh
nothing to do with
uh with 19 and we have and we
want recently started and um
yeah and there's a couple more to do to
start shortly so yeah
it's still going on great and
jonathan we have time for one more
question so let's wrap with this one
if customers wish to transfer their
design into you for manufacture
do you have a preferred suppliers you'd
prefer to work with
for reagents pads membranes etc
or are you open in your approach to
whatever works best in the development
yeah so um a term we often use is we
are in theory
particle materials agnostic
so you know it's very much a case of
looking what has been used perhaps
to develop in the test development
before it comes in before it comes into
abundance
um we have very strong relationships
with
all of the main suppliers um
not just for the sort of usual sort of
suspect
in terms of religious materials but also
housings etc so
we would very much be focused on what's
best for the test
what what's best to
um deliver a test in which meets
those uh initials of
test specifications is it's going to
deliver a test which meets
the end user requirements but we
certainly wouldn't be
um looking to crowbar in a particular
material you know in into that test
um you know we we don't actually
manufacture so nanoparticles
ourselves and so we're very much open to
what's the best material to fit that
test
specification and what we've done
previously
if they can be improved if there is
something that we know of
and we certainly will discuss that with
the
customer and um you know and a decision
can then be made but we certainly
wouldn't be looking to
change things for the sake of it great
and jonathan unfortunately we're out of
time we had so many great questions
coming in there's
quite a few that we weren't able to
answer but do you have any final
comments for our audience
um i mean the
uh i think we're going to
i think a lot more people are now um
aware of lateral flow assays um
there's probably been a mix in the media
of sort of good reviews bad reviews and
based on current world events
and um i think where
where there's there may be negative
press i mean i think that's
primarily down to um corners being cut
um things not being thought through
completely and you know and
test being rushed out onto the market
okay so
i it's a it's
and i say um type which is going to be
with us again for
you know for decades as it has been um
previously and um i think
for the industry that there's certainly
a challenge in but also exciting
few years ahead of us sure
that makes sense um so
jonathan thank you so much uh so
appreciate your time
um i wanted to remind you thank you and
i do
we want to remind our audience that
those questions that we did not answer
and any of those that are submitted
during the on-demand period
they will be addressed via email um
yeah so this presentation will be
available for on-demand viewing
i just want to remind you to share with
your colleagues who might be interested
in today's topic
and don't miss out on other
presentations on our agenda
thank you again for participating and we
hope you have a great day
thanks for joining us